انفجار وخزان غاز يستخدم لمنظومه تدفئه في
احد المنازل بمحافظه السليمانيه تسبب
بمقتل 15 مدنيا وجرح 13 من بينهم نساء
واطفال بحسب ارقام الرسميه فالتحقيقات
الاوليه اشارت الى ان الانفجار الضخم كان
سببه خلل فني وان كميه مخزون الغاز السائل
كانت كبيره جدا ما حول المنزل ذات الثلاثه
طوابق الى اثر بعد عين في ثواني معدوده
اصابنا الحزن والهم كانت كارثه كبيره لا
نستطيع التعبير عنها نعزي ضحايا الحديثه
وندعو بالشفاء للمصابين الجرح كنائب لرئيس
الاقليمي ونرجو ان تكون تلك تجربه
للمواطنين حتى ياخذ حذرهم من حوادث الغاز
اي مفقود ونتمنى الشفاء العاجل الجرح اه
وسوف تتكفل الحكومه بكل مصاريفها
الدفاع المدني الذي انهى عمليات الانقاذ
خلال 17 ساعه متواصله قال ان عمليات
الانقاذ تمت بمشاركه اكثر من عشر فرق
مختصه فيما طلب مواطنون السلطات المحليه
باتخاذ اجراءات تحول دون تكرار هذه
الكارثه على حد قولهم احنا ما نعرف اكو
غلط اكو شيء احنا ما ما نعرف بس همم احنا
نريد ان لا تتكرر هذا هذا
همم شو اسمه هذا
الماسه هذا الحادثه
سلطاته اقليمي كردستان العراق اخذت على
عتيقها تعويض ذوي الضحايا وتكفلت بعلاجهم
واتخاذ
الاجراء الى للحد من تكرار هكذا حوادث
احمد الحمداني العربيه محافظه السليمانيه